merci présidente merci président
également et merci aussi à tous les
intervenants alors moi je suis sénatrice
de la Guyane pour la Guyane qui est un
territoire qui est assez particulier
puisque vous le savez 50% de la
population à moins de 25 ans en ce
moment les enfants font des enfants
c'est un territoire qui subit une forte
immigration et quand j'étais mère je me
souviens que mon objectif était
justement de créer une école des parents
et des éducateurs bon j'ai commencé par
mettre les mardis les mardis de la
parentalité c'est à dire que nous
organisions des réunions avec des mamans
de papa aussi d'ailleurs sur des thèmes
bien précis sur la contraception sur les
stupéfiants sur l'autorisation parentale
en fait et c'était quand même des
réunions qui étaient très suivies il y
avait beaucoup de parents qui se
déplaçaient et en fait bon on attendait
un peu pour créer et là franchement
j'avoue que
nous allons en tout cas je ferai tout
pour que la personnes s'inspire de vos
expériences notamment donc l'école des
parents éducateurs parce que c'est un
vieux en tout cas de la ville de Cayenne
et puis aussi l'Observatoire de la
parentalité moi je crois que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment voir
et puis le rayonnement régional c'est à
dire que bon il y a la Guadeloupe il y a
la Martinique il y a la Guyane ce serait
bien aussi qu'on se met tous ensemble
pour pouvoir travailler sur sur ce
dossier et et vous dire c'est vrai que
j'ai beaucoup apprécié en tout cas vos
interventions les unes comme les autres
les messieurs et franchement je me ferai
un devoir en tout cas chaque fois que je
me rendrai sur mon territoire de
rencontrer les assistants de maternelles
les associations qui s'occupent des
parents parce qu'il faut savoir qu'en
Guyane il y a beaucoup de familles
plutôt matriarcales et les femmes ont
besoin d'aide elles ont besoin d'aide
elles ont besoin de soutien et vous
pouvez compter sur moi en tout cas quand
je vais retourner chez moi je parlerai
de de l'école des parents et éducateurs
dont on rêvait à l'époque et bon je
pense que ça va ça continue puisque nous
avions mis en place des maisons de
quartier de disposions de 12 maisons de
cas quartier sur le territoire de
Cayenne et c'était vraiment des espaces
d'échanges où on pouvait donc apporter
une discuter en tout cas sur n'importe
quel sujet en tout cas merci beaucoup et
merci aussi à la commission parce que ça
me permettait en tout cas d'être en lien
avec avec des acteurs très dynamiques
sur la parentalité merci président